[Music]
under the shadow of covert 19
and deepening concerns over a new
security law
this was a subdued national day for many
people here
but at a ceremony attended by hong
kong's political
elite the territories leader carrie lam
said the legislation
had brought stability over the past
three months
the plain truth is and it is obvious to
see
that stability has been restored to
society while national security has been
safeguarded
and our people can continue to enjoy
their basic rights and freedoms
in accordance with the law
[Music]
some not on the guest list try to stage
a demonstration
outside the venue a protest
that was quickly extinguished by police
on a day when they were braced for
trouble riot officers
sealed off a busy shopping area ready to
act quickly
to stamp out any signs of unrest they'd
earlier denied permission for a march
citing covet 19 and the potential for
violence
we cannot have a well organized valid
today but i think most of the hong kong
people
will come out at the street to express
their
anger there were many arrests
taking to more than 10 000 the number of
people detained in protests since last
june
the combined effect of the new security
law plus social distancing measures
means
we've seen no repeat of the mass
protests of a year ago
conventional demonstrating in hong kong
is now effectively over
but the movement behind the protests
continues
so people have had to become more
creative in how they protest
like displaying the newspaper most
critical of the government
there was some overt resistance though
with heckling
[Music]
and chanting of pro-independent slogans
in the chinese capital beijing the mood
was very different
not a mask in sight at a ceremony in
tiananmen square
a mass gathering that would be hard to
imagine
in many other countries today and a
reminder
of how life in china is returning to
normal a week-long holiday
is likely to be a test though of the
country's success
in controlling the virus adrian brown al
jazeera hong kong